i've noticed this trend it's like this
is like more of a
a red pill in general thing right
but they often talk about the nuclear
family
right it's like the nuclear family is
dying
feminism is killing it or has killed it
and etc cetera these women are not built
for making families and i'm like okay
well i'm mad at it you can say that a
lot of modern changes that we've made to
society definitely do not enable us
right to have the same type of families
that we used to have agreed i agree when
you preach to people that they need to
get 50 bodies before they can really
settle down how is that contributing to
the nuclear family
just be be careful how you use my name
your name did i feel it you said preach
no
i'm just kidding
my question stance go ahead how does
that if you preach that how does that
contribute
i mean
you could say that
i really tried
i tried i have nothing
my question is how are a lot of these
things in any way conducive
to building the nuclear family
some of these dudes are talking about
having like multiple wives and doing all
this stuff do you think that's the
nuclear family
it's not you know when you got multiple
wives you got to split your time with
and different families how is that
contributing to a stable household you
running out here raising your chances
but i mean
raising the chances of having your kids
out of wedlock with strangers that you
don't even know you only like them for
their looks like how is that choosing
one a good mother for your kids and two
um creating a stable environment for
them when you don't want to be with the
mother like i just find it funny
sometimes
where it honestly feels like we're
always pulling at two extremes right
it's like these people like the nuclear
family the nuclear family is like what
are you contributing to make sure that
that thing is staying intact you're not
right it's become now a
self-preservation thing from women in
for men
yes which is understandable right women
are basically saying i've been [ __ ]
over by society for so long i didn't
have any autonomy no none of my dreams
mattered i was basically told to breed
and stay at home and cook and clean so
like no i'm an individual who wants to
do [ __ ] so i'm gonna go live my best
life birth control exists i want to have
all this sexual freedom right and women
are now discovering that hey listen
going around [ __ ] every dude on the
block is actually not rewarding then you
have the opposite end of the spectrum
whereas guys right and now guys are kind
of being left behind right there their
place in the world is almost gone yeah
right because like they're not in school
they're not needed they're told that
they don't want it right women can do
all bad by themselves right they're
being pushed out of education a lot of
workplaces even the daily market like
there's far more male versions there's
going to be female versions generally
like the odds you get laid as an average
dude or ugly dude far lower so finding a
mating opportunity becomes much more
difficult right and so they engage in
this self-preservation thing where
they're like well women are to blame for
my issues the modern woman is not worth
even dating or spending time on because
they're entitled twerking losers some
you know what i mean then the women are
like well there's modern men are just
misogynists who want to perpetuate the
patriarchy and not take the
responsibility so we have both sides
nobody's talking to you both sides being
like the other is a problem and nobody's
talking to you right and even you hear
them sometimes you hear ladies be like
girl you're the prize you're the best
yes you hear that guess what don't lower
your standards yeah well guess what i
started hearing the red pill dudes be
like man you're the price you choose
when the relationship happens you so
they're doing the same speech
but to a different crowd that's
disaffected or disenfranchised when it
comes to the day like every bad step
they take they blame it on each other
yes the man and the woman yeah this is a
this is a
you guys are purple
i don't care i'm not a pill i'm a human
being okay yeah but you got i don't even
go above by the rules that you go so you
can call me whatever the [ __ ] you want i
don't give a [ __ ] but
everybody's pointing the finger
at everybody else yeah
for the bad stick that they taking it's
like i said i think a bad step yeah
[ __ ] why did you make the floor crack
that's what you that's what they're
doing yo
but
so so it goes on it goes on nobody
nobody everybody's mad everybody's mad
nobody's
can you just can y'all just [ __ ]
okay y'all y'all could just be [ __ ]
right now
other than throwing hands y'all could be
instead of being yeah but yeah but yeah
but
it's like a chainsaw by battle it's like
yo
y'all could be [ __ ] right now or not
and here here's here's a discussion that
you have to have at some point because
you're going to realize some things
don't overlap the things that get you to
the dance aren't the things are going to
keep you dancing no my car doesn't make
me dance
right you got the id to get in don't
mean you got the skills to keep going oh
right the things that will lead you to
having the opportunities to succeed
aren't the things that are going to keep
you succeeding meaning
i might have the great flash idea that's
going to make up for a great business
plan but what sustains a business is a
completely different set of skills why
am i saying this because a lot of times
the ideas that are focused on within the
red pill community like the mantras are
great for getting women
you get what i'm saying yeah yeah i mean
like these things will work if you want
to get laid right you go to these pickup
coaches and stuff like that you want to
get laid a lot of these ideas will work
your your your body account is going to
increase
undoubtedly but when it comes to
sustaining long-term relationships
those are not the skills that are going
to help you with that now there's going
to be some overlap that sense the
confidence that you develop that comfort
that you feel talking the opposite sex
all that stuff great but there are a
completely different set of skills
that require you to tone some of that
down that you will need for your
relationship to last right so you might
need to be brazen and confident and do
all this other stuff to be able to get
there cool
but once you get in the relationship you
have to understand the importance of
compromise it's like what's your end
goal
right my own goal
i want to be married at some point i'd
like to have a few kids i'd like to be
able to be with the mother of my kids
right that's important to me right i
don't i don't play with that i don't
want to frivolously have kids like that
zero interest in doing that what they
teach
right
other than like guys understand what
marriage is which i think is always a
good idea because you should know what
you're getting into if you're going to
sign that contract
other than that
none of it's conducive
to the ideas that'll help you sustain a
long marriage no it's about a lot of is
about by clout
we talk about
showing off and bags and it's a lot of
things about
like
pick apart this thing you know when you
you have to peacock and stuff like that
yes the cars
the this that and this is the third
that's that's peacocking that's based on
pic pickup artistry you know yeah but
after that even if you
i'm not gonna go there so so once you
get that you get you get that girl you
get whatever you had
it's exactly what you said it's a
difference it's a different set of
skills it's a different thing
i got lucky i got lucky that i didn't
have to chase
and i got my girl and i learned all of
that
after
with comedy with with customer service
and things like that you know what i
mean but i had i had i had a father and
a mother next to me to tell me how to
show me how a family was working and
that's not something that you're going
to find in any book or any pick-up
artist is going to be able to show you
right that's not that's not the thing
you know
you used to say this a lot but you say
like
a lot of this just comes from a place of
hurt
yeah well
yeah
i'm gonna answer your question
absolutely yes and what the world
doesn't do a good job is acknowledging
the struggles
of
of both
genders in a way well of man they don't
of both genders of both if you want to
say especially men i would be entitled
to agree with you right men's issues are
often being placed on the back burner or
being told they're unimportant and if
you bring them up you're an in-cell
you're a men's rights activist but when
someone just opens up to you just look
at the super bowl fitty sam was fat
lizzle was empowering
right there
go ahead and so
you you create a section of society that
feels alienated it feels like their
issues are not voiced
so it's kind of like that video i did
before where i said like the red pill is
necessary it's like well you got no
platforms to really speak to these dudes
you get what i'm saying like
you mad about who they found but you
don't even allow for healthy
alternatives
or don't encourage them or don't support
them or don't feel like they're valid
right only now you're starting to see
people like i see men's issues like to
some degree but it's like it's taking a
long time right there's been a lot of
suffering that these people have endured
and been told like your problems aren't
valid right in the same token it's like
women were saying like yo listen this
man put his hands on me right he did
things to me and everyone's like nah nah
nah nah that's not real it's like look
you know what that invalidation will
affect you call the police next time
yeah this time she did that's messed up
you know i'm saying so in the same token
women have dealt with issues for a long
period of time as well right where their
stuff was invalidated now they're being
heard forget it's great go but now
they're thinking like man y'all ain't
got promise are you serious
you know i mean like when we own most of
the like self deletions you don't think
we got issues like what you talking
about right important right when dudes
getting shafted in family court and in
marriages like what are you talking
about like i would lose my mind
i would lose my [ __ ] mind if i was
married to somebody i'm off to work she
banging the next dude now i gotta leave
my house and i gotta pay her a bunch of
money i would lose momma it's impossible
as a dude not to read that [ __ ] and be
like oh [ __ ]
it couldn't be me
murder's on
hey murder's on the menu
right i'm not we're not saying it's
right it's not but
it's not i understand that some people
go there it's not it's not it's messed
up it messes with you it's not but
here's the thing just because you're in
that place of hurt doesn't mean
everything that you hear that appeals to
you or that's
um calling to you
is
for your good when i worked in
telemarketing we had people we knew who
were at risk were susceptible to scams
who did we target the people who were
susceptible right so what they would do
right and i call it a scam not because
it actually was no it wasn't it wasn't a
scam it was completely legal yeah but if
you worked inside you knew it was a scam
you target the people that are old
lonely
that don't have nobody to talk to
definitely so what i'm saying is you as
a man also have to ask yourself are you
angry or upset or bothered by certain
things if most of us are honest we're
probably going to say yes to some degree
because if you've seen female
entitlement if you've seen a lot of this
nonsense there's reasons okay i'm not
saying what you're feeling is invalid
i'm saying that i get it
but you have to ask yourself because you
have this emotional response to some
degree to
things that you see happening into the
world
can people pray and manipulate on that
and it takes
a lot of self-reflection to be like you
know what i was a bit susceptible
you know if i'm looking at this
objectively
i can agree that some of this is not
good here's an example they'll say a lot
of times oh women don't be out there
[ __ ] around right because then you
can't pair bond statistics prove this
you know what the statistics also say
they say that it's also bad for dudes to
be out there because it makes it harder
for you to pair bond as well this is
important information why because if
we're telling people yeah you want a
marriage you want a marriage don't get
with these women who out there [ __ ]
because they can't parabolic well if you
engage in that same behavior it also
reduces your odds and anybody usually
what you're going to know is also a
pattern of these dudes who are out here
[ __ ] left right and center doing all
this other stuff generally they have a
lot of kids out of wedlock generally
it's hard for them to hold on a
relationship or a marriage some of them
have never even been in a marriage they
just go from girl to girl to girls
sometimes at the same time now you have
to ask yourself do you want to be doing
that for the rest of your life
so maybe there's some things in how
they're living their lives and the
things that they're preaching that is
not for you all i'm saying is this to
summarize so basically what you're
saying is is are you pissed off
and if you're pissed off are they
feeding you being pissed off
and if they feeding you being pissed off
is it from a good place or they're just
praying on you were you ever pissed off
yeah
but
through learning in life experience i've
had to learn that some of the things i
was pissed off about were unjustified
also some of the ideas that i completely
thought here's here's what i get really
like i find i get weird if i see someone
being dogmatic i take i take a step back
if you see the world in too much of a
black and white
because i know my life has been gray
i know the things i've been dealt with
have been nuanced i've known people who
were criminals who were really wonderful
people yeah right and that's a
complicated thing everything is not a
disney movie it's not it's not right so
i had to learn through observing the
world that like yo maybe some of my
ideas are not good you know when i'm
seeing stable relationships that are
lasting 25 30 years and i'm observing
these people and how content and good
they are with their life and you got
people telling me your marriage is
useless and all this other stuff i'm
like but what they're living is is
showing me something completely
different it seems like there's
tremendous amount of value in that you
know
i've seen how they don't apply to this
whole idea that the man always leads and
like they're not so rigid and everything
and yet they find a good balance and it
seems super healthy like that interests
me i have to open my eyes to be like i
can't view everything in the black and
white the bad news is that black and
white is a lot easier
it is
blm people are bad you don't have
supporters are terrible people
anti-vaxxers are to blame you don't have
order vaccinations
you don't have to think you don't have
to do the work to think to be able to
analyze things that's the thing that's
hard analyzing taking a situation and
taking yourself out of the context right
and being able to analyze that that's
the thing that's hard right but if
everybody everything is already chewed
up and be like you already have an
opinion yeah yeah it's that's like that
i didn't have to think about that i
didn't have to think about myself i
didn't have to think for myself to be
like hmm is it really like that yeah how
does thing really function yeah what's
the statistic on that how does that
really work who really does that but
that's that's asking all those questions
and having the hands and finding the
answers to that is really hard yeah
but it is if you already had a chewed up
shoot up uh the chewed up information
you just go with that and that's that
yeah
just just keep your eyes open that's all
man
that's all
anything else you want to add build that
fence make it comfortable there you go
and watch both people's view that's it
make sure you clean the yard get your
broom in your dustpan sweep it all up
all right make sure everything's clear
all right get the dust out of here
that's right cool if they tell you the
challenge to a fight yes